hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to aftonbuilt as always
there is a flashing lights loud noises
and jump-scare warning
i'm hoping there was a jump scare when i
did that this is an interesting game
because if i read correctly this was a
proposed game for the um five nights at
freddy's fan verse but it didn't make it
in or it was rejected by scott
for reasons that i know not enough about
to explain here however i just want to
see if the game can stand
on its own because
like i say a lot with these games is
they don't have to be a five nights at
freddy's game if you have a scary
concept you can just make your own
animatronics and sell it as your own
game it doesn't even have to be
animatronics it could be any kind of
monster if you have a great piece you
know
what what what
why'd it get quiet
hmm anyway if you've got a great concept
like i have to make the game
but apparently there's a lot of
placeholder stuff like i'm assuming that
this is
this
oh look at this
that's a full on cut scene i mean it's
like a storyboard for a cutscene but hey
a
probably storyboard more than like a
house
[Music]
fazbear fright
is that
is this based off like five nights at
freddy's 3
i think i might have read something
about that
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
oh no
[Music]
okay mission accomplished i think
everything's good and i don't have to
worry about anything at all
we did good guys
we did it
what did we do
i don't know what we did let's see that
that's what i'm talking about that
didn't have to be fazbear fright that
could have been any kind of strange
building you name it whatever you call
it like
uh you call it i wanted to say mickey's
pizzeria but that would be disney i
don't think that's gonna fly you could
call it um
scotch tots yeah that's also that's from
the office and also scott cawthon might
not like that uh sir
flubs a lot
sir flubs a lot fun fair sir flub's a
lot's fun fair and for some reason you
got to go it's on fire and you got to go
in there and get something out of it it
didn't even say what it was it was just
like you gotta get the real one out it's
worth more than my hat and then you're
done and then good instead of aftonbuilt
you call it fatten built you call it
tawnaf built you call it on taft on fat
built athen built
you call it
bafta ilt you call it la
laugh tony baloney
laugh tony baloney laugh tony baloney's
laughapalooza boom you got a game
everyone wants to see whoa
well i don't want to play that i don't
want to play that at all
oh hey
let's get past the stereos i think i
need some tutorials
pretty sure yeah look at this is this uh
from the goofy movies this is the map
that they use anyway i'm gonna go home
because i'm done with this
look at all this
look at all this at lifetony's
laughapalooza
is that the real laugh tony
is that is that for tony baloney
laugh tony baloney
all the kids love laughs tony baloney
look at that
wow
what am i doing
oh memory that's probably not good
[Music]
oh oh
um
oh oh
what what
f
i am suddenly in the game now
pick up the hand unit well welcome loyal
employee and thank you for using the
afton robotics personal assistant device
as stated in clause 374 of your employee
handbook
since we value the physical fitness and
strength of all our employees in case of
emergencies we will start your routine
with some exercise
what am i hearing steven the minor
physical effort known as moving
great if you are unable to move please
contact an afton robotics representative
at the number
55580
what am i doing why can't i turn
can i
i have to click and drag no
my mouse just wasn't active in here
before okay um
yeah what's that all about
yeah what's that all about what's all
this about what is any of this about
what are you about oh what are you about
what what what what did i what i'm wha
wha wha
why
what
why am i am i making out am i making out
with this why was i making out with that
why why why did i just make out with
that
all right well that was interesting
that's an experience i think it's some
kind of a mechanic where i can clamber
up on things
oh
i'm blue
okay all right okay see i can see some
polish in this you know the movement is
quite fluid you know perfectly now these
pairs down by bending your knee joints
those don't like to do that i know we
can depend on you making a quick escape
if necessary
speaking of speed how about you show us
what you got
i'm pretty quick look at me
congratulations you've exceeded our last
measured record of no connection to
database please contact your supervisor
to collect your badge at listed fee
in case of certain situations listed in
class 87 it might be a safe bet to take
to higher ground
if you have not neglected your upper arm
training routine you should be able to
climb anything up to
1.5
times you're a height
okay
okay what am i doing while i'm over here
i don't exactly know
do i have a flashlight
huh yeah the movement system pretty good
you know i'm not gonna lie
that's pretty cool
[Music]
i'm i'm trying what
oh there oh okay there we go i got it
okay then i come over here
whoa
okay all right we're we're we're cooking
the jumping from thing to thing is a
little odd
i have to admit but it does work
sometimes which means that it's going to
not work when i needed to and then i'm
going to die a horrible death probably
due to some animatronic named la phony
baloney
[Music]
what
the
hell
is growing on this
[Music]
oh good
great oh i can see now and there's bugs
well this is all just as bad as i
imagined that it was going to be so uh
guess i'll just go back to uploading
whatever file that was and then playing
on my phone
maybe uh
maybe play some video games or something
i don't know watch a markiplier video
maybe watch in space with markiplier
that sounds like something good to do
with my time or listen to distractible
the past the hours maybe make out with
this thing a few more times excuse me
smooch time
[Music]
drippy no way
whoa it's drippy i can't make out with
it anymore but it's it's so drippy
absolutely i don't know i keep bouncing
away from it what what is this movement
all right whatever
what was i doing uh and why was i doing
it hmm replace our pet on a duck wham
[Music]
well
it's been a long time since i've been
able to get out of that miserable suit
i do owe myself one for making a work
after all
interesting
it doesn't look like this
workshop is regulated
uh hello
is anyone here
hello
hello oh you're actually talking over
there hello you'll have to excuse my
poor communication skills i've
i've just awoken from a very
terrible nightmare and i need a lot of
help
you're the one who freed me from the
suit correct
oh i'm like the captain from space
i see
i guess i owe you a favor for that
i apologize if this is a lot of
information to take in right now if you
can lift me out of the stock i'll give
the liberty of explaining everything
okay
[Music]
all right uh judging by the look on your
face
you seem shocked that i'm even here and
i'm sure you've got a lot of questions
you'd like answered
this form that i currently inhabit
it's less than ideal
you seem to be quite smart if you're
able to free me after so long so
now that we're both here
why don't we strike a deal
if you can help me regain possession of
my true form i can show you endless
possibilities
the type of things people people dream
of
control over life itself
well we best get started
let's see the calendar
whoa
that doesn't look good
2023.
that makes things a little more
complicated than i anticipated
uh this material that we're after it has
a shelf life
however it can stay fresh and useful if
it remains
inhabited like me for example this
remnant we're after
it'll be harder to obtain but i have no
doubt that the two of us have the
capabilities to acquire it in order to
protect my life's work of creation and
manufacturing the canisters that held
the remnant were fitted with tamper
locks that would ignite and burn if
someone other than me tried to get a
hold of them i've interfaced your
goggles to detect these you should see
it in your overlay now
oh
sure there's only two left in this one
then again this model looks like it's
been through hell and back a long time
ago we tried to expand our franchise to
the southwest in arizona much further
than the original restaurant the
managers had to cool the models down
every so often with ice packs because
the plastic shells kept deforming from
the heat
trust me i'm glad i never went back
there
if we find an animatronic with an
inhabited remnant core there's a high
chance it'll be hostile
and on guard mode
we'll have to stun them using our
surroundings before we're able to pry
their tamper locks off
uh try moving our friend here in front
of that scooper arm
oh you want me to scoop drippy
this is legitimately drippy i cannot
believe it but this is
percent drippy find this anyway these
things aren't exactly public knowledge
the power cord usually leads to the
button to activate it it should speak
for itself
okay i push button
how do i get up a to button
ah
how do i get to the button i
what how do i get to the button there's
no ladder i can't climb that
i can't climb that
can't jump up that
can't go there oh do i know there was an
incident long ago where freddie was left
on his guard mode during the day
he ended up calling the police on the
franchise owner
as it turns out the owner didn't do
anything wrong
he just looked familiar
hmm what is this a ramp
oh why
ow
oh
my god my hops
my hops are nuts ah tool wheel to bring
up stun bombs and detonate bombs that
are inside you can dead stun freddy
what what
what
okay
a small bomb yeah better than using my
hand definitely
put a bomb on the button
that feels right
oh my god
trippy
drippy no hitting animatronics with an
external device will cause them to be
stunned for a short while during this
window walk up and interact with them in
order to remove a tamper lock correct
skill checks remove one tamper lock
while perfect skill checks remove two
you must remove all tamper locks before
you can finish off an animatronic for
good
well would you look at that still works
after all those
you've been years it well i hope
uh so once you've removed all the tamper
locks we can get to removing the remnant
core
but that process can be very long
our best bet is to disable the
animatronic permanently unless you
happen to have some dynamite or highly
explosive weaponry laying around in here
then we'll have to utilize the
environment around us to finish it off
for good
uh do you have a map lying around
anywhere i'll note down the locations of
the active remnant chorus
okay
return to my van
where is my van
is my van over in the other area here
this is a whole lot of information for
me to just be suddenly okay with i am on
board with this plane of volunteering to
disable all these horrible animatronics
that actually have secret life
in them
um
oh in this demo of aftonbuild you are
given access to most of the game's tools
in the full game you will not
i'm good
i think a lot of tutorials
mr can do's garbage disposal previously
the secret laboratory and research
division of afton robotics hidden in an
old excavation site
this location was abandoned once afton
disappeared and soon sold to the highest
bidder
it is now a sight of a junkyard in the
graveyard
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm doing
lixie and make it funny late make me
funny
i trust you i know you got this anyway i
can't do that texas kentucky california
can i do any of these i did it i don't
know why clicking on it before didn't
work
but now i'm gonna go into this
probably i bet there's gonna be other
game mechanics that i'm not 100 aware of
but i think it has to do with like
finding an animatronic that's going to
try to kill me and then trying to
disable it
remove the animatronics tamper locks
close all flooding valves what gain
entry to flow control room what
what do you want me to do
what
so is it here or something
is it like here right now
do i need to run
should i be running
hello
boy howdy this is a lot of animatronics
um
hi
okay
oh that's not good
that's never good you know i'm gonna go
ahead and say
uh that's not good
uh
why didn't that break my bones the other
one kind of did oh
hi
hi chica
hi
how you doing
good to see you
what
why
what is happening
what
is happening
what did i do i just saw something
what is happening
what is that
oh my god
oh my god
left hand right with what with what
what am i interacting with i have i'm
dead i sealed myself down into the
sewers or something oh
i somehow closed all the flooding valves
okay
do i have a camera oh i can place a
camera oh i see
i'll put it right here i guess
all right that's a nice camera
uh i saw that i don't know what that was
but i saw it
kind of gross down here
hi hey what's up freddy
or should i say laugh with talony
but low you have your face is still
a face hi
i don't know why i need to do that
oh my god
oh my god okay why
oh boy oh it's oh it's a big foxy dog
oh it's a foxy dog
oh i'm in a junk yard it's like a it's
like a a foxy guard dog
okay so there's something here
probably below that oh that would have
been perfect for that okay how do i
where's my tablet
what's like about the oh there it is
okay hey poochy
hey
poochy
hey
come here
where are you
hey wow you're dumb
you're uh you're kind of dumb ain't you
who got your tail
oh wait what happened to that do i have
a taser with this thing
do i have a taser
oh my god do i have a taser are you
serious
oh wait don't do that
don't do that
get down here i'm gonna zap you i'm
gonna zap you
laughalony baloney is only gonna mess
with me yeah come on come on okay yeah
three two one
why didn't it do the thing oh god oh my
god dude do the damn thing yeah
hi yeah i'm stuck i'm being bit a lot i
don't understa i am panicking i'm
panicking i'm pure panicking oh god
let's try that again maybe i should have
read the tutorial no i can figure this
out
so i open this with middle mouse button
so if i place this down
bam okay
that's good to know
i must have an unlimited amount of those
so what was it doing not blowing it up
what was that all about
huh
what is that a hey
bonnie how you doing oh man you have
seen better days pal all right there you
are
well guess what
guess what
you're about to get a face full of
explosives
let's come a little closer
let's come a little closer huh
don't come any closer don't come any
closer you would never you'd never punch
a man with glasses would you so this is
now there
hey
you
guys whoa
i'm down here now what are you gonna do
about it
and come on down
why don't you come on down if you're so
scared
where are you going
come on oh god he came on down
okay come on dude come here you come
here you
okay get ready three
two
one
and a half
and a quarter
oh god
you stalking me more like a rat than a
wolf god i've got him done but it did
not work again why didn't it work
you bastard
why
you're an a-hole stop being an a-hole
oh my god don't do this to me do i have
to like be in line of sight or something
is that what he needs what about my
needs what about what i need why is it
always so concerned about what it needs
what about me
this is a relationship with built on
sharing
please
please
oh come on
i'm gonna tase you in the ass
zap it about
what is it what is the what is the the
the sticks
haha got you now
watch this
a wqz got it cca
oh oh oh oops i did something wrong all
right that's fine
uh my jumps never work apparently oh god
okay that's fine that's fine watch this
nonsense
i'm going to do it again unless that's
broken now
looks like it might be broken now unless
it's not oh my god please jump
oh my god please jump
oh my god
jump
uh maybe i can't jump when i have that
out i don't know
jump
what is happening
i can no longer jump
there is no more jump okay and now i
have no idea how to get out of the
trenches
where
oh my god okay
okay i'm out now all right interesting
why was i not able to jump anymore
okay where's uh where's the yeah this
will be good
okay right here perfect perfect
perfect this will definitely work this
time where you at big boy where you at
hey who's got a big butt
who's got the biggest butt around while
youtube but you know i'm not looking for
you right now who's a lumpy bumpy
huh
who's a lumpy bumpy
lumpy but dumpy oh my god
i don't really like the clamber
mechanics if i could be very honest i
don't really think it but again this is
just a demo i don't want to criticize
anything about it because i'm playing
the physical embodiment of crushed
dreams and the last thing i would want
to do is kick the developer when they're
already down
oh there you are get your ass over here
my goodness i've added up from here with
you
got him
all right here we go
hey easy got it hey
um
that's okay
hey you got up quick
you got a quick ah i'm stuck on nothing
again let's see if it works twice
where yeah come here you
come here
turn around
look behind you dummy
hey
oh there we go
what really
really
really
ho ho ho
yi
come here
come here are you
where are you
come here are you
hey
champ
hey take a look over here champ that's
right
that's right it's your favorite snack
why would you not do it that's the time
you do it damn it
and you're annoying oh you're you're a
lot oh my god don't do it don't do it
this i'm not happy with the inconsistent
is it how are you still behind me
please don't i don't want to die i'm
dead i'm gonna die i'm i'm gonna i'm
done to die
okay hell hold on go oh my god get over
the thing
jeez you're quick can i please not get
caught up on that
okay here we go
and at that exact moment is when you
don't follow me anymore
aha okay i just need to stun it real
quick so i can get farther away
and that's what i'm gonna do and that's
what i did and that's what i did and
i've done it
oh my god you're really behind me aren't
you oh get stunned [ __ ] oh my god come
over here
get oh my god please
oh my god i'm gonna die but you're also
going to die because i'm about to do
this
please please god damn you oh my god
hey it's just a demo it's a demo of
crush streams it's a demo of crush
streams it's a demo of crushed streams
it's crushed dreams if i criticize it i
would crush it even more that it's
already crushed and i won't do that i'm
not a bastard i would never [ __ ] all
over someone's crush streams
it's really nice for what it is and i
need to remember that
it's not that the controls are bad
because they're not
everything's great
i'm happy
i'm very happy can't you see how happy i
am all right i'm gonna get the mechanics
of this goddamn what i really don't like
okay first off
this this this bam click
this
click
how far away bam it works perfect this
around the corner no line of sight does
not work you must
be in line aside okay that clear concise
the whole
mechanics of that stuff need to just
learn to deal that's what i gotta do so
theoretically
all right line of sight bam instantly
try to lean it over on the right i
probably get better line of sight run
right here comes right there oh no
surprises
i got this oh is that a little bit of a
oh is that a big mover oh is that a big
buffer doofer oh why don't you come on
over here who's a big boy who's a big
boy who's a big ball
won't you come over here big boy
oh come on over here
i'm gonna give you a scoopy doofy
yeah come on over here and uh take one
for the team
give me your give me your insights
oh god i am
oh god i'm stuck i'm stuck hit it i'm
hit just i'm gonna hit you again
give me your stuff
e
what i literally press e it said e i
pressed e
it said e i pressed e
s oh are you kidding me i am literally
pressing the correct button
okay i'm looking at it w
okay there must be something what did
that say about that what was that about
the taser
that looked like a taste i i'm not gonna
lie that
what is this about how do you taste
i don't know how to tase
[Music]
i might have bugged it guys i am
pressing the correct buttons it's just
not doing it
[Music]
nope
okay so no tasing i don't know why
i think it might just be bugged let me
uh
let me just die i think what it was is
nobody expects someone to be that bad
that quick and therefore
obviously
i deserve that hi
so how were you following me so quickly
oh
okay
got him
all right
c q q access
thank
you ah damn it
okay whoa oh no
oh damn it i don't know what what was
that
why do i keep bugging it
it is not my intention to bargain and
yet it keeps being bogged
whoa area not available in the demo what
are you talking about what do you mean
area not available in the bill i don't
even know where i went i don't even know
what i was doing
how would i know what is and is not
available in the demo
okay
you come over here oh how am i gonna see
you
i gotta do full ring around the rosie on
this one hey
let's play ring around the rosie
pockets full of posies whoa
pop pockets full of posies
pocket full of posie
you want posey pocket
hello i'm here to play
okay working
i think the thing it
is
you just can't do it multiple times uh
after you've already gotten some
successful things right oh my god
oh my god
hey bubby
it's a puppy
did i get it yeah it did
[Music]
ah did i get that i think i got it okay
yi
okay oh
right there you are come along
come along little doggy
come along little doggy
little doggy whoa little doggy
i think there might be some grabby hands
that grab it around this pile which is
advantageous for me come along little
doogie
little dookie
doggy
i do not like that
[Music]
what i messed that up
i pressed the wrong button there that
was completely my bad that was one
hundred percent of my bad
yo come on
let's go
and shovels
oh my god it's it's oh my god no
just oh my god real oh my god
i will not [ __ ] all over the crushed
dreams that scott cawthon already shot
all over i will not do it i refuse to do
it i will not do it i am better than
that i am better than that i am better
than that i am better than that i am
better than [ __ ] on the crushed
stamped on
destroyed torn up shredded dreams of
someone who only wanted to be a part of
the five nights at freddy's fan of hers
but was
horrifically rejected
i will not do it i would never it would
be such a horrible soul-rending reminder
of the failures i'm so sorry
i really don't mean any of that it is uh
this is a shockingly
well put together game beautiful too but
you know any grievances i might have or
simply that it's me being
just uh
just a silly billy
now i don't know what i think what it is
is actually he whoa no this one garbage
pile is the bane of my existence i think
he himself is blocking it
so for some reason
it's uh
[Music]
ah damn it
for some reason his own body is what's
causing it to uh
be a problem so uh yeah what i'm trying
to say is that uh foxy's too fat
for me to get a good signal on uh my
bombs
there we go
[Music]
yes
i think i got that whoa
ah i thought i got him maybe nope
i get one more maybe let's see if i can
screw this one up
oh oh god it was oh my god i am so
i don't know how i continually screw up
this one moment get it
jesus he almost got me again
here
did i get it did i get him
how many do you need how many do you
need how many do you need
all right
please let this be the last one
[Music]
what i hit q what do you mean what do
you mean what do you mean
oh god
i i i i don't know what that was about
that was weird okay i'll try it one more
time if not i i don't know what else i'm
supposed to do hell whoa oh you're
sparking now i saw that i saw the puff
spark if you get there and
yeah he body blocks it sometimes so
interesting
okay
oh damn it
but uh that was pretty good you know
hello
more like a rat you know the more i look
at it like a rat why are you chasing me
what is happening
are you chasing me
oh definitely
100
and that's not blowing up for some
reason
what
what are you friendly now
are you are you friendly
sniff my hand
who's a good boy oh who's a good boy
[Music]
i was not kissing you right on the lips
i was giving you kisses on your nose
[Music]
look at you
look at you you're cute you were just
hungry weren't you oh you were just
hungry oh he was a good boy oh it's a
good ball oh boy mission accomplished i
think i set out to do what i meant to do
and i did that thing that i intended to
do so i'm gonna consider that a job well
done for all the frustration i had i i
do think that this is an example of
something that's really trying to do a
lot and you know succeeding at a lot of
it clearly this game doesn't have the
polish that it needed but they presented
this to scott i think in a demo form to
showcase what they could do and clearly
they can do a lot this is quite
impressive if this was any other game it
would still need a lot more polish but i
mean if there was just like a different
skin on this like this would be a
completely different game and you know
you can build your own universe and you
can do all kinds of stuff with this and
you can have a lot of fun with it and
and to be perfectly honest like why not
oop
i have no idea
can i rotate this
i can wham
wow oh don't be afraid
oh don't be afraid it's okay whoa
oh hey whoa hey whoa poochie no it was a
joke it was a joke poochie all right
well uh he's a bit temperamental after
that i i did
blast him in the face with some some
light hey
now you you watch yourself now all right
well but i but i think i can leave this
one here this was a lot of fun and i
think there is some
there is something to this to be said
about this is like yes go make your own
things you know just because it wasn't
meant for the fan of verse doesn't mean
you can't do that and i know that like
that's easy for me to say right it's
easy for me to say but hey i'll play it
i'll play it guaranteed 100 this is
great thank you everybody so much for
watching check out more five nights at
freddy's games and fan games that i've
played in the link in the description
below and just go to my channel and
check out the playlist there's a lot of
them oh who's a good boochie thank you
again everybody so much for watching and
as always i will see you
in the next video
bye say bye
say bye fuji say bye bubba say
[Music]
you